if you missed part one of our reaction
to the finale link is in the description
box and pin
comment in the meantime here's our
reaction to part two which also features
the
review doors
holy [ __ ] oh my god
what oh
how
that was so surprising oh [ __ ]
whoa wow that was shocking
was there any hints at all should you do
some [ __ ] like that at this show
let me know how
how why'd you bring everyone
what was the point
oh no she has all their powers
she just did the [ __ ] five thing
and of course five is knocked out right
now she has their strength too
what is she like rogue or something yeah
what is going on
is she gonna rumor her dude
oh that's right they haven't met
oh damn
i know alison can fight this well
who is she what are your what's your
deal why's she so excited by it you
[ __ ] psychopath
no damn that was a surprise
she's like rogue dude
no no oh [ __ ] that no way
no come on buddy
oh
oh she collects kids with powers that's
her thing
uh what if har grave collected this the
reason he couldn't find
the other ones because the seven are the
only ones he could get to
here
[Laughter]
there's still lila out there y'all might
as well just be one of us
she's an eighth sibling or ninth are we
surprised
are they going there
she's not our biological sister none of
you guys are biological
like so [ __ ] right
[Laughter]
oh really so her power is mirroring
owie
[Music]
the show is insane that's so good
[Laughter]
she just said she faked it
please join the umbrella academy let's
join
you were born first
spit that truth luther spit that truth
i don't live the
can be your best oh i hope this works
please
oh i really hope this works please join
them i really hope this works
please please i feel like you're setting
me up to mislead me
please join us you're trying to mislead
[Music]
holy [ __ ]
oh my god oh my god
oh my god no what the
[ __ ] oh it's five shot two yeah but she
has their powers she could turn back
she'd go back in time or something right
but she's she's her thing's mirroring
at least it worked
[Laughter]
oh what is happening right now
it's harlan do something
yes goddamn please what is happening
this is so [ __ ] up
how what is what is going to happen oh
thank god oh if i survived
what not not decades seconds
sweet sweet
[Music]
hell yeah [ __ ] her
i think he's in the time terms like
seconds
[Music]
who chose not to no he's just
reverse he's going back right oh right
what a shot this is so great
hell yeah
should let her answer though so she can
get her definitive hate
oh no luck lila
well y'all can stop him
that was the journey of the swedes
oh she left the bracelet behind how was
that
oh yeah harlan yeah there's a whole
situation happening
[Music]
no [ __ ] given she taking it back from
him
oh she's taking it back oh damn i hope
that doesn't kill him cause that's the
thing that
brought him back to life in the first
place
holy moly molly okay good not gonna kill
the kid
he's gonna have pogo's voice
well done children good thank you
all you were necessary team
[Laughter]
except for class and
luther to a certain extent
[Laughter]
i don't know but i love it
he acts like he knows everything about
it
[Laughter]
we never even thought
oh no she's not going to leave
why she's never reason to carl's been
around
something happens and what if we're
separated
there's definitely it's definitely
better in 19 in
2000 2019 definitely arguments you can
make here barney
she's a danger now because she's on the
run going with her would put her in more
danger she feels
what
what umbrella academy does
it's a beautiful thing that's what this
family does best
family that's what luther said vin
diesel be proud
bunch of briefcases oh yeah it's [ __ ]
time it's just
yeah oh
let's take two this is very sweet i
guess that makes sense
hey he's back
oh you can put your arm around her
that's nice oh
probably couldn't save david though
david
no way [ __ ] unleashes a power oh you
still got a power
just can control it suspicious look
i'm gonna kill you
all mom wait
[Music]
they did it and they're back
there's another apocalypse outside
good [ __ ] y'all
which means pogo's not dead does that
mean hargreaves never died
ben's still dead
you guys though history
cause they went back to their future
uh-oh
that pen oh
what what is happening oh oh
damn what a setup whoa
okay pull me in again they just never
solve a problem do they
just keep digging themselves in deeper
holes
i'm gonna look forward to making the
thumbnail for this one
which moment well overall i thought this
was a better season than one
thousand percent i thought season one
was a great season i like i love the
show but this one just felt
way more focused had a lot of heart to
it as well there wasn't
a single week episode every episode was
great there was something surprising
moving in every single episode i'd still
say the sixth episode when they all meet
the dad uh in the restaurant are still
my favorite that's six or seven
six yeah i still think that's my
favorite of the season and i would say
this is the final episode is
this is my second favorite yeah i will
say this is a better finale than the
season one finale
season one family was great but just
seeing them come together as a team
for the first time since the beginning
well no in episode six but
yeah this is the first time since the
beginning of season two was really
it was really nice to see well it's like
they all came together last time
to take down vanya and this time they
all come together to help vanya
yeah yeah you know it's like they're
learning and they're having character
growth well they actually feel like a
real family this time around every step
of the way and then up to its final
moments they feel like an
actual family and brothers and sisters
and with this weird wiggle room where
we're like yeah but they can still like
you know bone each other if they want
yeah
why not they're not biologically related
that was diego's main concern yeah
i mean luther has that concern too but
there's so much to talk about
i mean let's get into it when they all
unite around vanya i thought that was so
beautiful because it was weird how it's
kind of jarring
a little bit a little yeah because i
thought there was a scene missing yeah
there was like a whole conversation off
camera that we didn't see
right of them going we should help but
they all kind of just show up i
appreciate the mislead and it's still a
rewarding moment when they all started
clamoring in the car
but at the same time i was like wait a
minute just like you guys seem a split
second ago
way too quick yeah that seemed like
there was some beat that was missing
probably had to take out for time or
or something i don't know yeah i
appreciate where it went though yeah
either way it's like the
conclusion we landed on i thought was
beautiful especially for the zavanya arc
that we got
and for them to unite together for
something that they didn't know what the
stakes necessarily
were just trusting her they were
reuniting not around an apocalypse
or trying to go against vanya but to
help her i thought was a beautiful thing
to help her and to help a kid
help a kid as well yeah tough little
baby boy harlan who still has a power
who still has
power twiddling that that duck thing he
had it's crazy all this showdown at the
farm you know
yeah all that sissy's farm when they're
helping out harland
and then when lila and handler show up
like okay where's this really going
where's this really going
right right it seemed like very super
heroey for all them to show up
all the assassins yeah and just the army
like onslaught of assassins with a
briefcase in in mass and i like that
they kept the fact that they all wear
masks like
kind of how hazel and cha-cha were the
masks yeah that's some interesting mask
they think are uh
universal and timeless masks
[Laughter]
these masks will be fine for any
they prevent chafing on the time trap
yeah well i do gotta
say though like i didn't quite get the
purpose of the whole show
because literally all you need is lila
all you need is her to do her [ __ ]
whatever that was she did me her mirror
thing it was very
very rogue from x-men without the
touching if anything you just lost
yourself a [ __ ] ton of assassins because
of this
for no reason like it was a cool moment
they all show up it's
it's intense but then some stuff was
kind of undercutting it for me where
they're all
firing and yet none of them can land a
single hit on
any of them i'm like there's a gazillion
bullets going around they're basically
the stormtroopers and that was really
trippy with the uh with diego when he
did the [ __ ]
the force thing i'm like i guess he can
control metal now i didn't know that was
his power i thought he just
had specific things over his blades but
i would say they would utilize that they
never
did i don't think they ever quite fully
explained how he's able to manipulate
the blades or why it's specifically
blades that he's able to manipulate
right um i just kind of rolled with it
yeah yeah sure why not him controlling
those bullets that was pretty nuts
this whole thing with lilo i love the
reveal of it and i love the additional
context it provides
for what the handler really does and the
bigger objective she has
she cares about power her finding lila
made me think that maybe she goes after
those kids as well and that's why harlem
is only able to get seven of them yeah
she got the other ones but now it's
making me
wonder if we watch this season back if
there was
any clues at all that she had powers
right
right because it's like the most mega
power like she's a threat to them all
the only way they're able to get her to
not kill them was a conversation
you know yeah they didn't have diego
there it would have been around they
were all trying to murder her the only
advantage i have is that she can
only use her the powers one at a time it
was never a hint that she could have the
powers at least something i totally
missed
no it came out it came out of nowhere
like right on the left field
but then i'm like looking back and i'm
going is there a scene
where it would have been necessary for
her to use a power
that that's the other flip side like was
it was there ever an essential scene
though where we needed to see a hint or
would have been like if she had these
powers she would have used them
but it does make sense not the fact that
she has powers with the fact that why
it shows early in the season why the
handler would go back and kill these
people just for this little girl so we
did get a hint of that and then why she
would fake
the documents or order them to be killed
in the first place because she knew this
girl had powers that's crazy and then
why she's also having eyes on harlan
so i think in terms of like how it all
ties together is brilliant
i think the one question this season
left me is how hazel played into all of
this
because he gave him the best season but
they never really like follow up with
like
how he knows what he knows and all of
that jazz i mean he he just gave the
photo of of hargraves at the jfk
assassination right
wasn't it the frankel footage that he
gave he did give the franco footage
the franco footage revealed the jfk
assassination and that
hard graves was there at the jfk
assassination i believe yeah man that's
the best
i i don't know so much i'll be
to keep track of right now yeah um
because yeah you have that at the
opening there's so many timelines now
too
there's like a gazillion timelines i
guess in season three they're going to
deal with alternatives well there was
i mean even i i forget it was like the
third or second and last episode of
season one where five created another
new timeline oh yeah
because he reversed all the events of
what happened yeah exactly and he
changes the timeline again and then you
got this
opening timeline of this season and now
you have this
new ending timeline you have the other
timeline where
old five goes back with different math
right
so there's a bunch of timelines now to
keep up with
i'm like
because like the way the the season
ended with season one
it ends on a cliffhanger like how this
one does but
that one i always felt like they ended
were like oh but the the conclusion of
the season is not done
right it felt like they left for oh but
there's still got like another episode
to get to
yeah it felt cheap a little bit it felt
like yeah it kind of ended abruptly
where they just time travel
out of the apocalypse we're here it's
like they still solved the 60s
time yes they still solve the problems
they had to solve for the most part here
they still have a conclusion we see they
definitively made it somewhere
yeah and then now we have a setup for
season three yes whereas the other one
was
oh i don't feel like you you concluded
it
i like the way this ends lila's powers
and her reveals i think are great
and i love the idea of setting her up
that she could possibly join an umbrella
yeah it felt reminiscent of kind of
other things like the the antagonist
like has the potential to be good like
join us and then something happens
you're like oh i can't so i feel like
they're going to get her eventually and
i think that's going to be a very
rewarding moment when she does finally
join the team in like future seasons
and i have a question about keeping the
eyes on harlan
was like the handler suddenly keeping
her eye on harlan once vanya gave
powers to him or was it uh
like was that always a part of the plan
in some way that this would happen like
she saw it in the timeline or something
i think with them going to the 60s it
was
maybe inevitable that would be a ripple
effect of him getting powers because
them being there in the first place
got it i mean we still didn't get some
answers there's still a lot of answers
we haven't gotten
oh yeah like the actual creation of them
of why they were all born and how they
were all born and then also
uh i think graves really is they did
yeah they did hint towards
that's where they're going to go in the
next season like oh like we know there's
another one of us yeah what else the dad
didn't tell us and i was wondering in
season one i'm like are they gonna
explore
the other ones because they said there's
like 40 different ones four different
babies that are powers i mean that's
that must be who the sparrow kids are he
chose like different kids right yeah
except for ben that would be interesting
and i must i'm under the presumption
that this
hargraves that we're looking at is the
one that they left behind in the sixties
timeline right thousand percent that's
gotta be him and
he's like you guys clearly screw up and
kept making mistakes because he knows
who they are
yeah so i went with different children
this time around yeah
that must be it that's what i'm thinking
he's doing no it makes sense none of the
silhouettes
looked like them or if they do use the
same actors and do like the whole double
actor thing
that luther wouldn't have the big eight
body benson had his like a brother
academy outfit on right
i think so i wonder if the the other
characters in the sparrow academy
i'm sure were like one google search
away from looking at a wikipedia page to
find out about sparrow academy in the
comics
i'm not sure who this cast of characters
is i mean i don't know what that giant
square box thing is that's floating
around with one of those characters whoa
what is that
yeah it's the mother box it's a dc
property yeah i'm not
i'm not sure what we're dealing with
here but i imagine that maybe
yeah obviously ben is part of his back
which is cool but i think it might be a
different cast of characters this time
around they all look like different
body types they don't look like the
shadows of the characters that we knew
no yeah um so they got it those are the
silhouettes of the actors they haven't
cast yet yeah exactly they were like we
don't know who we cast yet
let's just get some silhouettes in there
we know ben's gonna be in there yeah
that's all that matters yeah i mean but
going back a little bit there's still
some
arcs that i don't think that they really
fully realized the whole thing with
allison
and rey ended in the last episode right
and right that was
their goodbye already yeah this was like
the final closure stamp here
i thought was an endearing moment and
then you also have uh vania and [ __ ]
that made sense to me you know the idea
wouldn't go back
i i could see a version of [ __ ] still
going to the future i thought there's a
lot of arguments she could have made but
i also see
sissy's arguments as to why she wouldn't
yeah and [ __ ] was also under the
impression that harlan didn't have any
of these powers and stuff
and then once you see harlan still with
some powers and giving his mom a weird
bright burn evil look well now it seems
like harlow would have been better off
going with you guys
makes me think we're going to see adult
harlan in the next season oh yeah
probably that'd be pretty cool it's kind
of a bummer i really felt
four none of them ended up with their
romance the people they were
romantically involved with diego doesn't
end up with lila i'm glad none of them
died though got none of this
none of them died but [ __ ] doesn't end
up with vanya i i mean her reasoning for
not going made sense you know allison
and ray obviously but they didn't even
really other than some cpr moment they
didn't really hint
at luther and allison trying to strike
up a romance again right i think they
didn't want to overcrowd
it without focusing on the love triangle
because there's other things at stake
true
in the season we're obviously getting a
season three i loved luther in this
season oh he was great i
i loved him in this season he was really
funny i didn't feel like he really had
much of an
arc though i mean he went from like no
like when i wanted to do
anything to do with them to like okay
i'll be part of my family yeah that's
pretty much
it his art was pretty early in the show
i mean but same thing with klaus like
some of them didn't get some arc
treatments i felt like they wanted to
entertain the david thing without really
fully fleshing it out they dropped the
alcoholic
thing well i mean i think that thing
with david at the end was also
demonstrating
that you know like there are some things
you just can't change and they're out of
your control and you don't have control
over certain
other people's choices and stuff like
that yeah and the academy is deep y'all
it is deep
yeah so that and and then uh it's like
ben
but other characters had like a really
fully realized arc as before because
like
in season one luther went from loyal
obedient
to his father and wanting to be the
leader to
come into the realization that
everything's a lie yeah and then having
that all stripped away from him
here he's kind of like yeah that's
pretty much it like i don't wanna be
involved okay i'm involved
i'm kind of dumb this season yeah the
really intelligent guy you saw in the
first season right not hearing this
he's just a lovable luck now this is i
like dumb luther
yeah it's great i mean it was weird
because in the
in the first episode of this season you
see them all working together in that
apocalypse and they all seem like
they're all necessary
right whereas in this final battle not
all that or necessarily like a few of
them really came in handy
didn't really do much in this one had
his army of the dead fight them but no
bonnie is one luther didn't really do
much
yeah yeah just kind of he did through
one punch and then
got through into a house i mean this
really felt like it was five in vanya's
season
yeah and the nda goes too fast
this is why you guys come here for the
top-notch reviews
the perfect analysis starting to review
the last episode in a whole season in
one video
that came into play for sure with the uh
in a great moment a really rewarding
i'll be at a tad predictable moment uh
with five time traveling seconds but it
was still rewarding
yeah it was cool the effect in which how
he kind of went through that yeah and i
liked seeing how when he time travels
back to second
i didn't know if that would be be he
like he time travels back a few seconds
and sees another version of himself
oh that would have been trippy you know
if like there's like uh you know what i
mean
i was back and there's like another five
there yeah and i i thought that's what
the complication of that would be but
apparently not these time travel roles
are so [ __ ] they're so they
it's whatever they want to do
the swedes though i'm not a big fan of
what they did with them this season they
weren't
the they weren't hazel and cha-cha but i
feel like the rest of the season kind of
makes up for that lack of those two
characters
this whole thing with the swedes showing
up to shoot but i knew that's what their
intention was because
at the last time we saw the swede he
like he scratched the little container
and realized it was fake
yeah so he was like the lady grabbed my
balls must kill her lady
though is the whole perfect impression
purpose of them being set up just for
that
yeah just so there's someone to take her
out i guess
to me what it felt like was they had
very generic characters
in in place of the assassins and then
occasionally they were just trying to
add some depth to them
they weren't characters they were plot
devices they were plot devices like oh
let's send off the brother and try to
give like this
i'm in pain or the brother killing
brother i appreciate that they
went out of their way to try to give
some nuance to them overall
it's like the way they have this
brilliant tire wrap up and tie around
with bringing everyone to the farm
was amazing and then the whole thing
with the swede was like
i don't know this whole thing was
shooting the handler could have been
given to someone else
could it make even one of the characters
to give a more impactful moment give it
to five
right now that would have made that
would have made more sense
yeah the swedes were just there as an
obstacle they were never meant to be
characters at least in the season which
is kind of unfortunate the role that
they filled was better
was better suited and better represented
in the last season well it seemed like
the
way they gave focus to them though was
they were setting them up to be
something more and i guess that's what
the lackluster part of them is
is i kept feeling like oh they're gonna
be something in
like so integral or such or one of
them's gonna be such a rich character
but not
no yeah they really spoke but yeah no
that could have definitely been used
better
uh but still five time traveling seconds
handler being like definitely has to be
killed off and she
survived the bulla boom to the head
having the fallout with lila that was
cool
i wish someone else had killed
the handler i really i wish it was like
five or something or lila she used to
ruin
her own mom or having that conversation
if the handler comes back in season
three
i'm gonna be like that i'm not gonna
like that yeah he killed this woman
twice already let her die
let her die and then this is about as
good as she can get yeah
it's about as great as she can get i
wouldn't be surprised uh with lila
if they brought her back to kind of
become an ultimate villain
i thought they did a great job on the
fake outs with lila yeah
the constant misleads and fake outs with
her of like she's gonna turn and be a
good
good person she's gonna turn no she's
not oh she is yeah i know she's not oh
she is and then even the second to last
episode i love diego oh no she wants to
kill him and then she shows up on the
farm you're like i know when she finds
out it's gonna be fine
oh my god she's got mega powers she's
gonna [ __ ]
try to murder them oh no no okay she's
no she's having a change of heart ah she
just conflicted
yeah the whole season i was like
wondering where this girl landed
probably my favorite new character this
season
oh easily yeah she's definitely the most
charming the most she felt like a main
character within this show like i would
watch a lilac show but what happened to
poco's pogo
back we need a little pogo where's grace
but i do kind of actually take back the
thing about klaus
because i forgot about the beginning of
this episode klaus
has that resolve with ben so much of his
the guilt that he carries around with
him i feel
is associated with the presence of ben
ben being let go
allows him to let go of some of the
guilt because he's had this ghost
following him around that he thought
stayed because of him yeah
when it wasn't his fault and i think uh
he was able to like go with some of that
i yeah yeah and i i think that scene in
the beginning
kind of gave me the implication that his
drinking
kind of maybe started because of ben's
death
there's a bit of an enabling situation
too yeah
the cycle occurred around there yeah you
probably have a really good point there
um also cuda the actor who played young
klaus because
he nailed it yeah i couldn't tell that
was his actual like the actor doing the
voice or
if they dubbed him with the guy who
plays class
there's something else about the audio
there i was like what's going on here
i can't tell if it's like a weird adr
situation or not yeah
yeah it sounded just like him it's not
like the actual actor trying to do a
younger voice or maybe the guy just did
that good of a job
maybe they'd maybe take a note from it
too and then cgi
yeah babies i thought it was really cool
that the whole entire season revolved
around this plot of
stopping the kennedy assassination or
stop at the the end of the world and
the final episode has to do with with
bonnie's storyline like that
that the fact that yeah that connected
to the end as opposed to what
the rest of the characters were
following i thought was really
interesting it was really clever
we still got to see her learn how to
control her powers exactly
this season did a great job of redeeming
vania they did they did a wonderful job
they did a great job with a lot of the
emotional resolve with all these
characters
vanya especially like her connection
with [ __ ] and harlan
and then even right down to wiping out
all the assassins of like damn look at
her
controlling the [ __ ] out of her power
yeah it's pretty badass
i like getting to see uh vania and klaus
have a little moment in the beginning i
thought that was very sweet
yeah even vania and diego on the stairs
there too yeah and like they're both
left without their loves
but they have each other you know i
didn't i didn't
put that together called visual
storytelling aaron only the best of us
can identify
and herb leader of the commission
the man i'm i'm let her be more
i'm excited to see more of her hopefully
the commission comes back in season
three
probably will because they have that
connection with them and he's tight with
her so like yo
what's good with the timeline what
happened man i also love this set up
here that doesn't
of this season three that it doesn't
seem like they're gonna be trying to
uh stop another apocalypse yeah but
they'll have to adjust to a new
lifestyle
yeah no i feel like only so many times
you can change the timeline and try to
get back to what it was before
i feel like the first season had like a
contained story they wanted to tell and
i feel like season two
really diverted from that story and
allowed it to
grant i haven't read the comics but if
to me it feels like
season two was setting up what the rest
of the show
is gonna be like season one was like we
have this story we wanna do like a loose
outline for what the comic was
i didn't read the comic but like i i
just know vague information about the
first season was based off of the first
arc of the comic but i feel like
the show feels like it's having its own
sort of direction right
point and we got season three to look
forward to either way i thought this was
a
wonderful season i thought they
concluded it pretty well journey's not
over now he's over journey's not over
i'll see you
in a year yeah we both have long gandalf
beer yeah
you have a clown's beard yeah i'll have
a clown spirit that'd be great well what
do you think of season two do you like
it more than season one what'd you think
of this finale what surprised you the
most leave your thoughts down below
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell
check us out on patreon thank you so
much for being here people
follow her on instagram see you guys
soon oh and a patron of the day shout
out
dawn pete i know you've been going
through a bit of a rough patch
lately but the name peter means a hell
of a lot
to give you an idea let me tell you what
the acronym of peter means
p stands for persistent
e stands for entertaining
t stands for tenacious
e stands for
energetic and the r stands for
resilient so peter
never give up never surrender galaxy
quest
hammer what a savings peter
love you man i hope you're being safe
right now and i hope you're able to take
care of your mental health during this
time
i know times can be challenged right now
but just you know keep on persisting
keep on doing what you can to develop
your creativity and your
mindset right now during that writing
trust me persistence wears down
resistance
persistence hey like peter peter's
persistent
[Music]